foreign
[Music]
hey what's going on and welcome back hot
ones fans fall it's in the air football
season hoodie weather back to school and
of course a brand new hot ones season 19
lineup to burn out our guests for the
remainder of the Year here she is in all
her glory and I have to say ain't she a
beaut I think some of the best design
labels that we've ever had for a hot
ones Gauntlet typically when we do these
sauce reveals we haven't shot any
episodes for the upcoming season yet
this time we have I've tried this lineup
in action and I'll say this the best
tasting hot ones Gauntlet that we've
ever had in the history of the show and
I'm not sure that it's close if you want
to get your hands on the season 19
lineup you know the drill at this point
heatness.com heatness.com to order let's
Dive Right In and I know that you
clocked it the second that you open up
the video the classic in its lead off
position but with an orange label
the classic continues to evolve with the
brand new chili Maple Edition we've been
chasing the perfect sweet heat
combination for years now and I think
that we've really cracked the code you
have maple syrup apple cider vinegar
Fresno chilies from the Legends smoking
Ed Curry himself I'm a sweet tooth call
me bias but to me my favorite version of
the classic that we've ever made all
right moving on to number two
Sinai Gourmet tropicante it joins us
from Montreal Canada but the flavors
come straight from the tropics
this sauce features a blend of fruits
like mango papaya banana and then it
also has some Scotch bonnet peppers so
even in the two position you're reminded
you're still on hot ones if you like
like a mix of banana ketchup and hot
sauce then this right here is the sauce
to use
all right moving on to Sauce number
three
and I don't just throw out compliments
like this okay but I mean this when I
tried this sauce I immediately thought
to myself Mount Rushmore right here Pico
Rico in the three spot top five hot
sauce I've ever had my life
Pico Peppers Pico Rico it's simple yet
potent balancing Savory and acidic notes
of garlic and lemon juice with just the
right amount of habanero heat Pico Rico
Pico Rico Pico Rico Pico Rico say it 10
times fast with your mouth on fire all
right moving on to number four
smoldering its way back into the lineup
hot ones Los Calientes barbacoa
our smokiest sauce of the Season thanks
to the flame kissed flavor of Applewood
smoked red jalapenos and dried Chipotle
chilies welcome back to the table old
friend all right moving on to number
five very interesting sauce here and the
number five spot now if you're a first
weed Feast completist you probably
remember Jing GAO she appeared on Feast
mansion with Rich Brian and joji she
taught us the art of the Sichuan Hot Pot
she's since then built a sauce Empire
with her brand flyby Jing and Sichuan
gold crafted in Chengdu is the first
time China's famous numbing spices hit
the hot ones table it has an oil base
very interesting and unlike anything
that we've really ever done in the hot
ones Gauntlet so keep an eye out for
very very unique reactions to our number
five sauce in the season 19 season
alright moving on to the back half and
we bring back one of our favorite
Hondurian hot sauce makers
turmeric bomb does what it says on the
label blasting you with turmeric and
then rounding out the wellness meets
pain Vibes with ginger Scotch bonnet
chocolate ghost and jalapeno peppers
turmeric bomb it isn't dub bomb but
still a very intense way to kick off
number six all right and moving on to
number seven at this point Karma first
ballot Hall of Fame hot Ones hot sauce
and it returns here in the seventh spot
the latest from sauce maker and former
NASA engineer Jean oloshock is a
Celestial mashup of two of the most
popular sauces Cosmic dumpling and
Scorpion Disco This sauce right here
takes Savory soy Citrus notes and then
they combine with red jalapenos and
scorpion peppers to take our guests and
blast them off into orbit if they're not
there already and if they're not there
even after number seven well they most
certainly will be there after number
eight the Greek philosopher Harris said
the only constant life is change wise
words but clearly the ancient Greeks
were not thinking about hot ones in the
number eight spot because cemented into
its place permanently it seems that way
to bomb in the number eight spot the
sauce that launched the shack I'm not
gonna make a face face it stays alright
moving on to number nine you know it's
difficult to bridge the bomb to the end
of the show but there's one man who's up
for the task it's smoking Ed Curry
the latest nine spotter from puckerbutt
combines Ed's famous Carolina Reaper
Scorpion and seven pot Primo Peppers the
major hit of savory garlic yet another
reason why we always recommend to
publicists that they make hot ones the
last press engagement of the day all
right and moving on to number 10 it's
the gold bottle
as always our journey up Mount Scoville
ends in a blaze of glory with the last
dab Apollo it's smoking adds Apollo
pepper and it's fresh powdered and pure
chili distillate form and there you have
it the season 19 hot ones lineup in all
of its Glory as always if you're
interested in trying right along with me
and our celebrity guests visit
keatonist.com to get your hands on the
season 19 hot ones Gauntlet and as you
know hot ones fans when you see the
sauce reveal that means that the season
is just around the corner I can't wait
to get back in this seat and delivering
the interviews that our fans love I will
see you very soon
you and me are probably similar in that
we've seen some of the craziest physical
reactions face to face with some of the
biggest stars in the world you know
if we took your reactions and put them
to my card tricks I'd have like a whole
new brand of magic yeah it'd be amazing
thank you so much for watching today's
video and hot ones fans I have a very
exciting announcement the hot ones Shake
Shack collab is finally here the hot
ones cheese fries the hot ones Burger
the hot ones chicken all made with a
shack sauce that includes hot ones the
classic along with the last dab it's
very spicy it's very delicious and it's
available for a limited time now through
the end of the year at Shake Shacks
Nationwide and via the Shake Shack app
be careful around your eyes and don't
forget to order a milkshake
[Music]